hey 42 here it's no secret that
america's been involved in a lot of wars
the longest of those is ongoing and
began in 1969 when president nixon
declared a war on drugs one of the aims
of this particular war is to get people
off rocks
by contrast in 1934
president roosevelt announced a war on
crime which intended to get some of the
most dangerous criminals onto
the rock or alcatraz prison as it was
more formally known
talk about mixed signals
alcatraz island was not the kind of
place you'd find in any holiday
brochures instead of sun lounges and
pina coladas it was home to a 19th
century fort which after some remodeling
and redecorating became a maximum
security prison welcoming its first
inmates in 1934.
over its 29 years of operation alcatraz
housed some of the most dangerous
criminals in history including george
machine gun kelly al capone and alvin
creepy carpus one of only six people in
history to have been officially named
public enemy number one in addition to
criminal heavyweights like these
alcatraz also housed prisoners who were
considered troublemakers especially
those who are the most likely to try and
break out there was a very good reason
for that not only was alcatraz
considered to be america's strongest
jail but thanks to the island's location
in san francisco bay with its cold
waters visiting great white sharks and
strong currents it was also thought to
be 100
escape proof
that reputation certainly didn't stop
inmates from trying to get out though in
all 36 prisoners attempted to escape the
island across 14 different attempts
the less imaginative just tried to make
a run for it the more determined
included two men who tried twice proving
that no matter what eminem might think
sometimes you do get more than one shot
though sadly they did miss their chance
blow of the 36 prisoners who tried to
escape 23 were caught six were shot and
killed two drowned and the further five
are recorded as missing presumed drowned
of those five
two very likely did drown
but for the other three well their
escape is arguably the most impressive
prison break ever recorded
except perhaps for that japanese super
guy and whilst the american prison
system may presume that they drowned
there's every reason to believe they
might just have made it
frank morris john anglin and clarence
anglin escaped from alcatraz prison late
at night on the 11th of june or possibly
in the early hours of the 12th of june
1962 never to be seen again
actually that's not entirely true but
more on that later
the investigation into this ingenious
escape would be aided by the fourth
member of the group the one who didn't
get away alan west though west would
claim to have been the brains behind the
plan the fact that he was the only one
who didn't escape cast some doubt on the
credibility of his story the more likely
mastermind was frank morris a career
criminal with an iq of 133 who had
already escaped once from the louisiana
state penitentiary while serving a
10-year stretch for bank robbery
after evading capture for a year he was
eventually rearrested during another
robbery and sent to alcatraz
joining west and morris in their
audacious bolt for freedom were john and
clarence anglin two brothers who did
everything together
as boys they were said to be strong
swimmers who impressed their siblings by
swimming in the freezing waters of lake
michigan whilst it still had ice
floating on its surface
just the type of training needed to
brave the frigid waters of san francisco
bay
the brothers remained inseparable as
adults sharing their favorite hobbies
like bank robbery and serving time
eventually finding their way to alcatraz
after numerous unsuccessful attempts to
bust out of atlanta prison the four men
knew each other from previous prison
sentences and were placed in adjoining
cells at alcatraz because obviously the
first thing you should do with inmates
known for jail breaks is to give them
the maximum opportunity to communicate
in private in december 1961 plans for
the great escape began with a focus on
the air vents found beneath the sink in
every inmate cell
with the help of some old saw blades
found around the prison grounds and
spoons stolen from the mess hall west
morris and the anglin boys widened the
ventilation shafts in their cells
so far so shawshank redemption but the
men's progress was accelerated with the
help of an ingenious drill fashioned
from scavenged items including the
engine from a vacuum cleaner west was
tasked with repairing by drilling
closely spaced holes around the air vent
cover a whole section of wall could be
removed and if you're wondering about
the noise drilling was done during music
hour when the prism was chorus with the
unholy din of various musical
instruments including morris's accordion
the enlarged holes allowed the four
prisoners to access an unguarded utility
corridor it might sound like they were
almost home and dry at this point but
this was just the first phase of a much
more complex plan
because escaping from the prison was
if anything the easy part
surviving the journey across the bay
would ultimately prove the difference
between success and failure not to
mention life and death
the water in san francisco bay is cold
and choppy and the current is strong
these days swimming enthusiasts
regularly make the two-mile crossing as
part of various charity swims and events
armed with wetsuits and large teams of
lifeguards the swim isn't overly
dangerous
attempting the swim in the middle of the
night in a prison outfit however would
be a death sentence for all but the most
accomplished of open water swimmers
rather than risk it west morris and the
england brothers had a better idea
why swim when you can sail trying to
steal a boat was far too risky
making one on the other hand
well it would be time consuming but time
is the one thing every prisoner has in
abundance
well that and bad lawyers
the utility corridor gave the escapees
access to the vacant top level of their
cell block a quiet never visited area of
the building that was absolutely perfect
for the creation of a secret workshop
over the course of six months the men
gradually constructed a six by fourteen
foot rubber raft
accompanying paddles a bunch of life
preservers and four imitation human
heads made from a mixture of concrete
dust soap toilet paper and toothpaste
these heads which would be left in the
prisoner's bed whilst they worked on the
boat and on the night they escaped were
completed with flesh-coloured paint
stolen from the art supplies and hair
provided by the prison's barber shop
if you're watching this video from
inside a maximum security prison
perhaps it's time you signed up for that
arts and crafts class
you have to be impressed by the amount
of patience ingenuity and discipline
that went into the escape plan but
morris west and the england were also
helped along by a healthy dose of good
fortune
the prisoners spent a lot of time
reading magazines and books from the
library
and even though all the publications
were censored to remove anything that
might aid and escape
two popular mechanics articles
made it past the filters and gave the
prisoners some real inspiration
at first glance it's easy to see how
these articles didn't raise alarm bells
the first handy article from the
november 1960 issue was about rubber
goose decoys made by a hunter
since the goose hunting options on
alcatraz island were a bit limited
prison officials understandably thought
this story harmless
but the piece included details of a
technique called vulcanizing which sadly
has nothing to do with dressing up like
spark but instead described how the
hunter bonded pieces of rubber together
the wannabe escape artist put the theory
into practice they stole or with the
help of other prisoners collected more
than 50 standard issue rubber prison
raincoats that they then used to make a
raft
the seams were carefully stitched and
held together using rubber cements
containing vulcanizing agents stolen
from the prison glove making and
cobbling shops
the vulcanizing process was completed
using the heat from nearby steam pipes
which hardened and sealed the rubber
making for a rudimentary but impressive
getaway boat
inflating the raft without a pump would
have been a difficult time-consuming and
potentially impossible task if you've
ever tried to inflate an air bed using
nothing but your lungs you'll know what
i mean
in fact i've seen a man pass out trying
to do just that
though unconsciousness in that case
could have had something to do with
excessive cider consumption
anyway with a stroke of genius macgyver
himself would have been proud of morris
solved the inflation problem by making a
pump out of a concertina a type of
musical instrument like a small
accordion that makes sound by being
pushed and pulled just like a set of
bellows
popular mechanics came to the rescue
again in march 1962 when the magazine
included a demo of life vests for ocean
travel a must for sailors senior
citizens on an ocean cruise and
prisoners trying to escape a maximum
security facility surrounded by open
water as we all know the first rule of
jailbreak is safety first
so with a raft life vests and paddles
made of old wood and leftover screws
the crew had transport from the island
sorted the next big question was how to
get out of the prison building itself
eventually they found a ventilation
shaft that led off the utility corridor
in advance of the great escape the
prisoners climbed the shaft to the roof
pried open the ventilator at the top and
then kept it in that position with a
bolt carved out of soap ready for the
big push when the time was just right
that time was the night of the 11th of
june 1962
when the men finally made a break for it
unfortunately for west though he was
unable to get out of his cell
west had built a full section of wall to
hold his vent in place and conceal the
expanded hole behind
but the cover-up had begun slipping and
west had used cement to reinforce the
concrete
this solved the slipping issue but he'd
done too good a job the cement had set
and he was unable to get the vent
removed in time the others tried to help
kick the vent in from the outside
but to no avail
when west finally managed to get out of
his cell later that night
the others had already gone and he was
forced to turn back
meanwhile morris and the anglin brothers
had scaled the ventilation shaft and
gotten onto the roof of the prison
they made quite a racquet in the process
and were actually heard by the guards
but they failed to follow up on it and
missed their best chance to apprehend
the group carrying their gear the trio
made their way across the roof then down
50 feet of piping to the ground
from there they scaled two 12-foot
perimeter fences and made their way to
the northeast of the island which was a
blind spot for the searchlights and
guard towers
it was here that they inflated their
raft and set sail
but for obvious reasons
this is also where that trail of
evidence runs cold
what did the men do
did they for example paddle to nearby
angel island where they could rest a
while before a short swim to the
mainland
that's what west claimed the plan was
when he was interrogated
but it's impossible to know if he was
sharing the real plan or making up a
cover story to throw the authorities off
the scent
there was also a reported sighting of an
unidentified white boat in the bay that
night fuelling speculation the trio
could have had outside help and been
picked up
whatever happened the men got a good
head start they were only discovered
missing the next morning
triggering a huge manhunt the search
covered both land and sea and involved
the military and various law enforcement
agencies
the men were never found but on the 14th
of june a paddle was spotted floating
close to the shore of angel island
later that day a wallet wrapped in
plastic was found nearby containing the
names and addresses of the anglin's
family and friends
another week would pass before what was
believed to be the remains of the raft
were found close to the golden gate
bridge and a day later a life vest was
retrieved from the water just off
alcatraz island
of course the tides and currents in the
bay had scattered these items all over
the place
making it impossible to draw any solid
conclusions about the escapees
whereabouts
so the authority stuck to the more
convenient story that the men had most
likely perished
even though the fbi wouldn't close their
case until 1979 the u.s marshals service
on the other hand still have an active
case open to this day
as the years have gone by claimed
sightings of the prisoners have abounded
along with multiple theories about their
movements members of the anglin family
say john and clarence's mother received
flowers every year along with a
christmas card apparently signed by the
brothers
rumor has it there was even a pair of
large and rather strange looking women
who turned up at her funeral
similarly two strange men were reported
to visit mr anglin senior to pay their
respects whilst he was in his funeral
home
these men didn't identify themselves but
apparently got very upset and left
rather suddenly
in 2015 a photo of the anglins came to
light which was apparently taken in 1975
by a family friend fred brizzy who
claimed to have met the brothers in
brazil
the photo shows two men in large
sunglasses next to a rock or termite
mound apparently on the farm that they
were said to own in brazil like the
brothers brizzy was a career criminal
and as a result both his story and his
photo were ignored but in 2020 facial
recognition software determined that the
photo was indeed of the anglin brothers
who had escaped from alcatraz all those
years before
in 2018 cbs news network released an
extract from a letter supposedly written
by john anglin which had been addressed
to the fbi and received by the san
francisco police in 2013.
in the letter john says the trio had
made it on the night of the escape but
only barely he revealed that he was 80
free and in bad shape with cancer as
well as the last man standing after his
brother and morris had passed away in
2005 and 2008.
john's reason for getting in touch was
apparently because he wanted to receive
treatment he offered to reveal his
location if the authorities announced on
tv that he would be given a one-year
sentence on turning himself in the fbi
kept the letter quiet and it seemed
nobody ever heard from the mystery man
again
the anglin family responded angrily
especially since the letter writer had
said he was dying but the fbi stuck to
their story as did the u.s marshals who
said the lead was without merit and
merely a hoax designed to embarrass the
authorities with so much water under the
golden gate bridge since june of 1962
it's extremely unlikely we'll ever find
out what really happened that night
but there are many lessons to take away
from this story like always keep your
old copies of popular mechanics you'll
never know when you'll need them next
thanks for watching